can we talk about your collaboration
with trisha yearwood i met her at an
award show a few years ago we were
talking about how when we get ready for
these red carpets it's
lettuce
and so we were we always i always go get
like a cheeseburger or something
afterwards
and so does she so we started talking
about our favorites
and then she said i should come on her
cooking show
but it was after lauren's appearance on
tricia southern kitchen that their
friendship blossomed and when i was
leaving that day
she said if you ever want to collaborate
let me know so i gave it about a week
and i called it
[Applause]
that collaboration is just one of many
powerful songs on lauren's album sitting
pretty on top of the
world first
[Music]
the singer-songwriter says it's one of
her most personal albums to date do you
ever get worried about the songs that
you write about other people
well the two
ex-boyfriends i don't think i'll hear
from
there are a couple of songs about
another guy that
i keep wondering if he's going to hear
him and reach out but i don't think he
will either and lauren will bear her
soul once again in her new book getting
good at being you out this november what
was that whole experience like for you
readiness
i tell about my parents divorce and my
dad's recovery with alcoholism and
my eating disorder along the way and how
each of those things kind of shaped me
into the person that i am it's all about
healing and i think the world really
needs healing right now
[Music]